a northwest valley neighborhood is
really turned upside down after
human remains found in the backyard of a
home we thank you for joining us on this
friday night at 11 i'm brian loftus
this all happened at a home near lake
mead and rampart now homicide detectives
they're trying to figure out what
exactly happened sasha loftus has been
on this story speaking with neighbors
all night she joins us live from the
area
now with the very latest sasha
brian this discovery really rocked this
entire neighborhood those who live
nearby
tell me this house appeared vacant for a
while and at times suspicious
but they were still surprised to see how
this all
unfolded i was shocked and i
i thought you know i was in a movie a
northwest valley neighborhood turns
tense and anxious after a gruesome
discovery
it's just kind of you know upsetting and
unnerving to know that that stuff's
going on
human remains were uncovered in the
backyard of this desert shore's home on
thursday they were putting you know the
body
you know out of the yard on the plastic
it was a blue plastic but it was a small
it was not a full body i don't think
metro sources say they found them after
receiving a tip on the address
and reports of two people seen digging
outside
all of a sudden i was like okay we have
to be a little more careful now those
who live here
tell us this just added to the fear they
were already feeling
as several incidents including this
deadly shooting
happened right around the corner last
year at this exact same time
last year his daughter woke us up here
i'm hearing gunshots while many are
still
shocked to hear about this latest
situation as a fan of
some horror movies and stuff he just
never expected to happen in real life
they vow to look out for each other and
hope things here
stay quiet in the future
now though this home did appear to be
vacant for quite a while according to
neighbors who live along this street
according to the clark county assessor's
office it does belong to a woman who's
in her 80s
now of course this story is still
developing it's still ongoing so stay
with 8 news now both on air
and online for the latest updates in the
coming days
reporting live in the northwest valley
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now